we've been following what's been going
on with the Keystone XL and Dakota
access pipelines and a few days into his
presidency you might remember that
Donald Trump signed that executive order
telling government agencies to remove
unnecessary and unnecessary roadblocks
and barriers to the construction of the
pipelines it didn't really do anything
but it was a bad sign that the president
was supportive of pipelines which we
shouldn't be building Donald Trump also
guaranteed multiple times that if and
when the pipeline is built it would be
built with American steel he actually
said this during his joint address in
front of a his address in front of a
joint session of Congress recently
remember this this took place while I
was getting ready to sign I said who
makes the pipes for the pipeline well
sir comes from all over the world
isn't that wonderful I said nope comes
from the United States or we're not
building it American steel
if they want a pipeline in the United
States they're gonna use pipe that's
made in the United States do we agree
you told Johnny that was actually from
CPAC he also said the same thing during
that a non State of the Union State of
the Union a few weeks ago now I already
told you that those were empty promises
okay because the steel for the project
has already been supplied and the steel
is not from the US so it's not getting
built with US Steel if it is indeed
built this is something Trump should
have known or maybe something he knew
and just chose to lie about it Trump's a
liar that's not the story here here's
the story as soon as the American Health
Care Act flopped last week people
started emailing me and we'll talk about
that later in the show people started
emailing me saying David this entire aah
a flop is distracting from the fact that
Donald Trump and the State Department
have issued a presidential permit to the
energy company TransCanada giving them
permission to start building the
pipeline in fact Donald Trump did one of
his ostentatious pomp and circumstance
signing ceremonies around this take a
look today I'm pleased to announce the
official approval of the presidential
permit for the Keystone XL pipeline
TransCanada will finally be allowed to
complete this long overdue project with
efficiency and speed so that's true
right Trump signed it but it still might
not happen but I was looking into more
of the details and I realized the entire
it's gonna use American steel
expectation is actually nonsense to
begin with the steel specifically is a
distraction in the sense that we
shouldn't be building pipelines but it's
an interesting conduit into another
aspect of this story the pipeline is
obviously not going to be built with
American steel even though part of the
pipeline will be in the US right which
is why US regulations are relevant here
this is a foreign owned pipeline being
built by a foreign owned company to
supply fossil fuels mostly to be used in
other countries the fact that it's
raising American resources is sort of a
side effect
this is really a foreign project Pat so
not only was Trump lying or uninformed
even the idea that hey very little of
this project other than using our
natural resources is actually going to
benefit financially or in terms of
energy people in the United States I
really don't think it's a bad idea to
try to push for using American steel
especially because the project's
actually going to take place within the
United States right but you have to
understand that that would violate
international trade law so I think he
was trying to use that as sort of a
bargaining chip but he didn't realize
this would violate NAFTA we can't do
this from the beginning and being the
president you should know that oh
there's the list of things Donald Trump
should know but doesn't is a
never-ending list and they're
furthermore there might even be a
conflict of interest when it comes to
Trump pushing for the construction of
the pipeline because the fifth biggest
shareholder in TransCanada the company
which would be building the pipeline is
Deutsche Bank who is owed three hundred
million dollars by Donald Trump from his
business dealings so this is all just
building the case that all along the
build with American steel thing was not
only nonsense but it continues to be a
distraction and Trump signing this also
doesn't mean that this pipeline is going
to be built any time soon the issue now
and this is it's this sick irony of
what's going on with fossil fuels demand
for tar sands oil is lower than it was
when the plan for the pipeline started
because oil prices have crashed and
companies have stopped investing as much
in tar sands projects in general during
this time shell has sold nearly half of
its tar sands assets Exxon Mobil has
written off 3.5 billion barrels of tar
sands oil and Trump I I really don't
know if he's clueless or lying he said
on Friday that this is the greatest
technology known to man or woman maybe
to the men and women in Trump's White
House but normal people are not amazed
by tar sands oil technology at this
point right because this is entirely for
the oil companies if he was going after
the American worker as you think it
would create more jobs than I think what
are the 30 permanent jobs
yeah perm a bunch of temporary jobs
during the building and then but
pipelines replace people driving around
in trucks right by their very nature
these projects destroy jobs so the lies
continue and you should be aware of them
as they take place today's program is
made possible in part by blue apron
delivering fresh ingredients to your
door for under 10 bucks per person per
meal and with blue aprons freshness
guarantee you can be sure that every
ingredient in your delivery will arrive
ready to cook or they will make it right
blue apron is the number one fresh
ingredient and recipe delivery service
in the country I've been a blue apron
customer at this point for many many
months some of the meals available in
April include spinach and fresh
mozzarella pizza with olives bell
peppers and ricotta sweet and sour
salmon with bok choy carrot and ginger
fried rice and parmesan crusted chicken
with creamy fettuccine and roasted
broccoli you can check out this week's
menu and get your first three meals for
free of course with free shipping by
going to blue apron comm slash Pakman
that is blue apron dot-com slash PA k ma
n